I'm Molly bloom back to you know Bobby
I'm Molly bloom
do you know about me major indictment
after I got you call that night and I
brought your book do you understand that
you are charged with operating an
illegal gambling business are you taking
me on to the claim
I'm at a bank you convinced my quad
isn't a flier on the whole process if
you think a princess can do it I did
you're incorrect I'm getting that you
don't think much of me but what if every
single one of your ill-informed
unsophisticated opinions well you will
be amazed
this is a true story but accept the my
own when I changed all the names and
Molly my weekly poker games moved to the
Cobra lunch you'll help run it
[Music]
in a room with movie stars directors and
business Titan they were going all in
all the time anything wrong
are you just so much
[Music]
I'm going to start paying my assistant
fine but no firing I'm just going to
stop paying you get paid once a week
from the game it doesn't seem clear
you're gonna stop paying me because I'm
making too much money doing my second
job and if I say no always both jobs
because it doesn't seem fair you're not
bargaining power here you are
unimportant you know hey which is what
Burnett sale how many didn't burn
witches with the myth they hanged him
The humiliation had given way to
blinding anger at my powerlessness I
wasn't going to wait before I put a plan
in place I'll be hosting a game in this
fleet every Tuesday night the first
buy-in 250,000 that's going to make
noise what you spent 8 years in
Hollywood and two years in the or
finding the world's most exclusive and
decadent mancave have you seen the other
names in your indictment come on Molly
just out deep into the Russian mob where
you hear exposures crazy and get 2.8
billion on this drink right now we're
going to get blown up we've managed to
build a multi-million dollar business
using not much more your whips I've got
to be charged in federal court well
nobody's perfect
there's a new offering complete immunity
we hand over the Han track team of my
family slides careers will be ruined
why yielding this alone where are the
people you're protecting by not telling
the whole story I tell them everything
they want to know about me it's about me
you